good morning Hank it's Tuesday so on the
day I met a EDA and majeeda at the Azraq
refugee camp in northern Jordan I also
met 16 year old whose Psalms hi oh yeah
good nice to meet you nice to meet you
who psalm is a truly extraordinary kid
who lives with his mother and younger
brother in a shelter with very little
furniture except a bookshelf which
contains the quran and a couple other
books i began by asking who saw him how
he learned to speak English and they
count you wanna do except yeah three
months upon study three months I
download some features from YouTube and
event
I lent three kings listening that's
right he learned from YouTube well and
he works with the tutor who's also a
Syrian refugee I go to him if eg if it'd
be unlikely and a warning when I have a
free time to spoke to him and say hey
teach me he has two accents American and
a pigeon with Jana and I are laughing
because for both of us that's one more
accent than we have
who saw him also studied English a
little bit back in Syria in fact he was
in English class when his school was
bombed so that we had English teacher
shouting played on and all the students
were laying in the ground so just how
art can shield the school with missiles
and this was with my friends without any
jokes but I guess was trying and I have
my friends who've died sad Sultana ran
in his name and actually it was a
terrible first ever so gonna consider
you think about your friend off yeah
yeah actually I was showing my his
photos and the school so yeah can you
show me this happened to be often in
Jordan the refugees I met almost never
had printed photographs instead they're
pictures of friends and family were on
phone sometimes on non-functioning
phones they kept charged only to access
the pictures houssam first showed me a
picture of blood on the floor of his
classroom and then he showed me his only
picture of his friend it was of a teen
boys corpse
his dead eyes staring up at the camera I
asked him if this is why his family had
left Syria yeah this moment they said no
school no walking the license it wasn't
safe so we should go to Jordan
so he set a better life but since then
who Psalms family has spread out I have
three parts of my family one in Syria
and one
and we are here and actually I have my
brother in Turkey his brother in Turkey
is on scholarship at university he has
two married sisters still in Syria and
his father an engineer and older brother
took the boats to cross into Europe more
than a year ago who saw him his mother
and younger brother are hoping to be
allowed to reunite with them soon in
Germany who saw him seems to genuinely
love learning he's a very successful
10th grader at the refugee camps high
school he also loves writing stories I
like to write of adventure stories so
somebody who lost in the forest then
he's like found some something's in the
night and he's like that right I liked
it but when I asked if he wanted to be a
writer or a translator when he grew up
he said no ha ha so the actual
engineering like my father Hudson Jim
finished my study when I finished I go
to a company in Cydia which helps the
Syrian people in Syria and to help
rebuild it but we yeah remember this my
dream I just said it's my content the
Korean country I love it so much this
young man has not seen his father his
sisters or two of his brothers in more
than a year and he knows that they can
only be reunited in a safe peaceful
Syria and that is his dream to rebuild
that country houssam also loves to sing
in fact he sang for us about Syria while
his mother wept when he has Yoona had
mom and so this young singer and writer
will hopefully one day soon be an
engineer I really admire that
professional goal houssam is a brilliant
and tremendously disciplined kid I mean
he learned English in three months he
could do anything but his greatest
ambition is to bring his talents to the
kind of work his country will need the
most and to me that's true heroism
Godspeed a song may your dreams come
true maybe a soldier in the Army
engineers that rebuilds your country
Hank Jana Rainey ha ha ha ha ha know me
and hug it and watch it again